[Music]
before we start this video
i just wanted to mention that only 21 of
you are subscribed
so if you enjoy the content please
consider subscribing to support the
channel
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter
theory in a few of my recent videos i've
discussed what happened to various
characters
character families after the events of
the final book film
the deathly hallows first i made a
theory video on what happened
to the dursleys then i explained what
happened to the malfoys
you guys seem to really enjoy this type
of video so i'm going to keep
going with this same general concept and
move on to the next wizarding family
the weasleys now right from the
beginning of harry potter
the weasleys immediately make their mark
we know and love the weasley family
for both their quirks and their kindness
to harry to the books films
they really are good people who have
nothing but harry's best interest
in mind coming from a bit of a broken
home harry spent countless days at the
weasley family home
and during those times molly weasley
took him in
like one of her own no questions asked
come christmas time
there was always a plate on the table
for harry and there was always a new
jumper knitted for him
but despite adopting a sort of
pseudo-foster child in harry
the weasley parents molly and arthur had
quite a few children of their own
the whole family consists of fred george
charlie
molly arthur ginny bill percy and of
course ron
obviously there are more weasleys but
these are the main ones that we're
introduced to
in the series anyway without further ado
i'm going to be discussing
what happened to each of the weasleys
after the events of the last book
first ron the epilogue certainly gives
away aspects of ron's future
particularly as he is shown sending his
children off to hogwarts at platform
nine and three quarters
alongside his new wife hermione granger
the bear had two children
rose and hugo granger weasley in the
epilogue
ron and hermione can be seen sending
rose off to hogwarts along with harry's
son albus
in addition to marrying hermione one
pursued the career path of an aura and
eventually became an aura for the
ministry of magic
jk rowling had this to say of ron
joining the ministry
harry and ron utterly revolutionized the
aura department rolling said
they are now the experts it doesn't
matter how old they are or what else
they've done
rolling also emphasized that by joining
the ministry harry and ron helped
revolutionize
it into a really good place to be they
made a new world
rolling said however ron didn't remain
in the ministry
forever and later left so that he could
help out his brother george weasley with
the weasley's wizard weezers
joke shop it has also been expressed
that despite ron's terrible driving
track record he did eventually obtain a
muggle driving license
even if he had to place a confundus
charm on the driving instructor to get
it
fred and george sadly fred didn't make
it past the battle of hogwarts
and that this had a profound impact on
the future life of his twin
george and hermione was struggling to
her feet in the wreckage
and three redheaded men were grouped on
the ground but the wall had blasted
apart
harry grabbed hermione's hand as they
staggered and stumbled over stone and
wood
no no no someone was shouting
no fred no and percy was shaking his
brother
and ron was kneeling beside them and
fred's eyes stared without seeing
the ghost of his last laugh still etched
upon his face
george and fred were the closest of
brothers identical in every way
and the kind of twins that would spend
every waking moment with one another
their friendship was beautiful and that
is why i find it unusual
that we were never provided with much
info about what happened to george after
the death of his twin
and brother in a 2007 interview with
bloomsbury
jk rowling was asked about what happened
to fred how is george getting along
without his twin
well i don't think that george would
ever get over losing fred which makes me
feel
so sad however he names his first child
and son fred
and he goes on to have a very successful
career helped by good old ron
the interview also confirms that george
continued working at the business which
she and his brother had created
ron joined george weasley's wizarding
weezers which became an enormous money
spinner
i find it as no surprise that george
would continue the family business
a business in the spirit of fun and
having a laugh is what fred would have
wanted
and continuing to work there would be
the best way to ensure that his spirit
lived on
furthermore in the documentary jk
rowling a year in the life
rowling dives into the weasley family
tree and mentions the following with
regards to george
a lot of readers asked me was george all
right and of course he wouldn't be all
right
would he that's the reality but i think
that he married angelina
it was actually fred's ex maybe it's a
bit unhealthy
but i think they would have been happy
as happy as he could be without fred
i think he really would have felt like
part of himself died
charlie though charlie didn't make an
appearance in the films he was certainly
present for the battle of hogwarts and
survived the battle
charlie never married nor had children
but got to spend his time with his
copious siblings
nieces and nephews being an outdoorsy
type of an affinity for dragons
charlie was more preoccupied with his
craft rather than pursuing ladies
apparently in the summer of 2014 nosy
journalist rita skeeter
began to question his prolonged celibacy
something that was obviously none of her
business
bill though bill survived the war and
the copious battles that transpired
he was at one point severely injured by
the notorious werewolf fenrir greyback
fortunately he avoided turning into a
werewolf but it has been expressed that
he did develop the tendency to enjoy
very rare stakes following the war bill
and his wife fleur
whom he married in 1997 had three
children victoire
dominique and louis weasley percy
though percy had begun to go down a bit
of a dubious path he did eventually make
up with his family during the battle of
hogwarts
percy survived the battle but like the
rest of his family
was significantly affected by the death
of his brother fred after the war
percy returned to work for the ministry
as a high-ranking official
under the new minister for magic
kingsley shacklebald he married a woman
named audrey and had two daughters molly
and lucy
molly was of course named after his
mother
ginny it probably shouldn't come as a
surprise to anyone that juni ended up
marrying the one and only harry potter
she was in love with him for years and
though the films didn't do a very good
job of portraying this relationship
they were meant to be the epilogue of
the film gives us just a glimpse of the
lady that ginny would become
where she is seen sending off her
children to hogwarts at platform nine
and three quarters
harry and jenny had three children james
albus and lily
immediately after graduating from
hogwarts however it has been reported
that ginny actually became a
professional quidditch player
going on to play for the holy head
harpies in the years that followed the
harry potter series
rolling provided other clues about
jenny's later life after retiring to
become a mother
junie joined on with a daily prophet and
became their official quidditch
correspondent
this position eventually matured and she
became the sports editor for the paper
molly and arthur last but not least
molly and arthur
first things first molly's heroic
actions during the second wizarding war
and her quite the reputation and she
became quite well known as the witch
that defeated and killed the notorious
death eater
bellatrix estranged arthur continued
working with the ministry of magic and
fought to improve mongol rights
with the help of kingsley shacklebolt
other than that
molly and arthur lived out the rest of
their days quietly enjoying the company
of their dozen grandchildren and that
basically sums up the lives of the
weasleys
after the events of the deathly hallows
after the war had ended
and after losing fred the weasleys were
probably closer than ever
each of them making a conscious effort
to prioritize what is most important
family and that's it for this video who
do you want to know about next
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
remember there is plenty to be learned
even from a bad teacher
what not to do how not to be
[Music]
you